[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena seu
podcast semanal onde a gente indica
troca ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente
lê ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo de
produto PR discussão eu sou o Artur e a
i tá com 36 semanas e ela tá do tamanho
de um melão agora e eu sou a x e a gente
não sabe que semana vai ter podcast que
semana que não vai ter né agora
dependendo da
aqui PR saber quando vem a licença
paternidade e no programa de hoje a
gente vai conversar com a uma grande
amiga minha aqui Fernanda faria sobre
como foi o Len e friend summit o
primeiro evento organizado pelo lenal né
do podcast daa que a gente sempre fala
aqui né de então bem-vinda F muito
obrigada pelo convite um prazer est aqui
trocar ideia sobre como foi Len and
Friends
me senti muito Friends do L ao que
amigos
Friends show de bola mas antes da gente
para esse papo tem Jabá aí Artur tem
Jabá mas antes do Jabá tem anúncio de
quem ganhou o último ingresso que a
gente já já a gente já divulgou por
conta da logística lá pro pro festival
mas a gente vai falar aqui também né é
isso só para lembrar então no último
episódio aqui do podcast a gente falou
que quem deixasse um comentário aqui
onde quer que seja a gente ia pegar os
nomes e a sortear o ingresso pro
festival mulheres de produto e aí ão
conta pra galera quem foi que levou esse
ingresso aqui no podcast que mais dá
desconto mais dá benefício dá ingresso
dá tudo do Brasil inclusive né foi o
podcast o episódio com mais comentários
na
história exatamente Muito obrigado a
gente adorou ver todos os comentários
não foi só comentario Zinho de quero
ingresso vou participar vários
comentários construtivos ali
contribuindo pra discussão super legal
continuem mandando aí pra gente onde
quer que você ouça Spotify YouTube subsc
todo lugar lá tem uma caixinha de
comentário PR você mandar pra gente a
vencedora foi a Manuele Soares e que ela
já até se inscreveu lá e é isso aí
parabéns nessa edição tem tem promoção
tem sorteio ou tem só Jabá agora tem só
o Jabá né da da próxima edição a última
do ano do curso desconto tem desconto
sempre sempre sempre
eh bom semana passada né as Big Tech
Tudo divulgaram os resultados a gente
publicou resumo lá na nossa News L na
brilliant Basics e mas um dos destaques
foi que juntando lá elas vão gastar
quase 200 milh de Doll em ai né já
anunciaram então assim imagina que que
vai por aí mas enfim se você quer fazer
essas conexões com Business entender um
pouco mais disso de números e como
resultados financeiros impactam e etc a
última edição vai ser dia 30 do ano né
oitava turma dia 30 de novembro eu não
sei se eu estarei tudo depende da i Mas
o Dudu vai est lá e e é isso dia 30 de
novembro online ao vivo 15% de desconto
já tem mais da metade das vagas já
preenchidas Então corre senão você vai
deixar comprar o último lote vai pagar
caro depois não vende churumela não é o
que a gente sempre fala aqui né não vai
deixar de ganhar desconto para pagar
mais caro na hora de perto né do do
curso muito bom Agora sim bora lá pra
pauta falar do evento antes de falar do
evento pede pra galera deixar o
comentário e
tal n mas é deixa lá ó se você ainda não
é inscrito no podcast se inscreve onde
quer que você ouça seja no YouTube seja
no Spotify seja em qualquer agregador de
Podcast que você usa Procura lá ó botão
de joinha botão de D estrela vai lá dá
cinco estrelas dá joinha porque isso
ajuda para caramba as ferramentas verem
que vocês estão gostando do podcast a
indicar para mais pessoas e deixa o
comentário como a gente falou os
comentários foram super legais de ler aí
então vai lá deixa seus comentários pra
gente também que a gente adora E aí a
gente traz aqui também na próxima edição
a gente pesca uns lá para trazer
aqui agora vamos de pauta vamos pra
pauta
agora bora lá para começar já vou deixar
um disclaimer aqui que a gente vai ter
que fazer um outro Episódio com a
Fernanda só para ser um episódio do
Product Hero né Tá mas hoje ela vai
contar um pouquinho da experiência dela
no len friends and summit mas antes se
apresenta aí pra galera F boa eh então
eu sou a Fernanda faria eu hoje tô como
diretora de produto e design na AB in
beb que é o Global da AMBEV cuidando dos
produtos Zé delivery e Tad delivery que
é o equivalente do Zé para América
Latina porque zé em espanhol não ia
fazer muito sentido
eh então criou-se uma nova marca chamada
tada é uma marca mais sonora que pode
usar em qualquer lugar do mundo que é
tada que é ligado à mágica é o Zé mais o
amigo que você chama pro churrasco então
Trabalho há 10 anos com produto um pouco
mais do que isso eu acho contar o
período que eu empreendi foi trabalhar
com produto Então tem um pouco mais mas
é isso assim tô super feliz de estar
aqui amo gravar podcast para mim é é um
uma forma de devolver pra comunidade o
que a comunidade me ajuda de
conhecimento tenho sempre isso em mente
e depois dessa intro aí só eu tava
lembrando aqui Inclusive queo a gente
falou do figma no episódio que a gente
falou da conferência e a gente ficou
questionando cara quem que poderia fazer
algo parecido barulhento assim etc e a
resposta claramente foi o Len né e ele
que escuta o nosso podcast né ouviu
Claro foi né porque el Caraca que ideia
ótima que esses caras tiveram e atendeu
nosso
pedido e aí rolou a primeira edição
recentemente foi um dia antes do meu
aniversário inclusive no dia 24 de
Outubro
e enfim contou com um montão de gente
tinha um monte de participante e
palestrante teve né a mirica capur que a
gente fala aqui direto tem a clar V shas
teve o Mike iger também né teve o Kevin
well da da antropic e da da Open ai né
os dois CPO das concorrentes ali teve
bom teve mais um montão de gente e teve
vários round tables também mas enfim só
um resumão agora a gente vai entrar no
Como foi de quem tava lá correspondente
internacional é isso e para começar
antes de falar do evento em si Fernando
queria que você falasse um pouquinho que
que te motivou a querer nesse evento eu
sou acho que como muitas pessoas de
produto fã do Len né então que escuta
vários podcasts eh vários episódios que
ele grava eu escuto inclusive uso
como ferramenta de de gestão de
stakeholder muitas vezes então
compartilho muitos dos podcasts né dos
episódios que o Len grava com os
stakeholders para ajudar no aprendizado
né no aprendizado contínuo e de fato Len
foi um dos
que conseguiu me ajudar mais nesse
processo de trazer os stakeholders para
entender um pouco mais do mundo de
produto
Então essa foi a primeira coisa assim
falei caramba a linguagem que ele usa
fica mais fácil para outras pessoas que
não são necessariamente de produto
entenderem então isso foi muito bom que
a gente sabe né de uma dificuldade
natural né uma posição que muitas vezes
você tá lidando com outras mudanças na
empresa
eh então primeiro foi isso e o
segundo eu tava sentindo falta de um
evento bom forte para você meio que blow
your mind assim para abrir um pouco a
mente ter outras perspectivas
eh acho que fazia tempo que eu não ia
num internacional
assim então já tinha ido no Mind the
product recomendo também é muito bom e
fora as pessoas que você conhece né
então tipo no final das contas a ideia o
conceito Ali era eles vão verificar
todas as pessoas que vão no evento São
pessoas que têm experiência em produto
que trabalham em produto isso para
trocar é muito bom porque no final das
contas você descobre que todo mundo tem
mesm problema mas pelo menos você se
sente acolhido entendeu no Leader também
rola a mesma coisa né a gente até
comentou NSS episódios atrás aqui no
final das contas os problemas são os
mesmos né só muda o carimbo e o
passaporte e e a a
moeda e você compartilhou no no Linkedin
que as duas palestras que mais te
impactaram foram as da Claire V né
falando sobre o futuro da gestão de
produtos com ai etc e da EB ataud eu não
sei se fala assim exatamente o nome dela
que falando sobre visão de produto né no
YouTube estudio e conta pra gente porque
que elas foram as que mais te impactaram
e que que você tirou de Insight
delas eu acho que são assuntos bem
diferentes assim da Claire
eh foi muito sobre né a palestra sobre
product Management vai morrer em breve
que é para gerar o impacto né então todo
mundo falou fodeu tô sem emprego né E aí
depois ela foi construindo em cima disso
foi muito bom a primeira reação falou eu
falei vou ter que vender minha
as artes na praia ferrou não tenho
alidade e ela trouxe muito uma questão
de pensa que com com avanço da
ai cada vez mais as tarefas que são suas
operacionais você vai começar a deixar
de fazer então eu criei um bote no chat
de PT que ele chama VP de produto
basicamente ele tem um monte de
metodologia de produto que eu gosto
Então eu selecionei as que eu gosto as
que eu não gosto eu não ensinei para ele
eu não falei para ele para saber
peguei as que eu gosto as que eu
acredito eh com outras coisas que eu
acredito treinei ele e coloquei algumas
informações de negócio também então ah
Quanto é o NPS do Zé eh puts decisões
estratégicas a gente tá indo para esse
caminho para aquele caminho tal e aí
quando eu tenho que fazer alguma
apresentação para mostrar para
stakeholders executivos e tal na verdade
quem faz a apresentação
é basicamente o o VP de produto né o bot
porque ele estrutura ele me ajuda a
organizar as ideias e aí fica muito mais
fácil de comunicar Até porque eu já
trouxe ali alguns indícios de como as
pessoas gostam de receber
informação e aí conectando nisso quando
ela trouxe Assim na verdade não é que
vai morrer é porque as pessoas vão
começar a ter mais habilidade então se
você parar e entrar no Cloud ai e ficar
brincando de Ah eu quero criar um
aplicativo que faça isso isso isso ah
que eu eu fiz um outro dia que era sobre
eu queria descobrir eh até onde a gente
conseguia fazer terapia online
eh e depois eu fico por um outro caminho
eu falei tá bom vamos para terapia
online então quero um guia um guia de
terapia pra pessoa saber qual é o melhor
tipo de terapia para ela dado o estado
dela e que outras terapias mais deveria
fazer E aí fui conversando com o clud
durante um tempão e ele vai codando e
criando a experiência O protótipo
navegável etc T tal tal eu falei beleza
Gostei dessa solução agora eu quero que
tenha essa Ui aqui né peguei um exemplo
colei lá e ele fez a a dentro da UI E aí
ela trouxe um conceito muito bom assim
não é que o o ai vai fazer 100% vai
fazer 100% ele vai chegar no 75 os 25
São seu mas esse 75 já vai te adiantar
muita coisa então o o conceito foi dado
que parte do que é operacional vai tá
sendo feito e que você consegue fazer
75% você como produto consegue criar
um protótipo eh para testar uma ideia
para validar uma hipótese sem
necessariamente envolver o time de
engenharia eh sem necessariamente até
ter uma pessoa pessa de design uma
pessoa de design vai conseguir criar
alguma coisa então o product TR Deixa de
ser product TR para ele começa a
unificar mais as pessoas têm múltiplos
né então beleza minha fortaleza é
produto eu sei de design de Tech eu não
sei codar mas eu sei usar a ferramenta
que faz codar então isso faz com que os
espectros de de de de funções que as
pessoas vão ter eles comecem a ser mais
amplos então vai ser menos sobre o
product e mais sobre pessoas com
multidisciplinaridade eh se
complementando então talvez para um
projeto ten uma pessoa que seja tipo uma
pessoa vai cuidar produto e design outra
pessoa vai se cuidar atc produto a gente
não sabe mas era é um pouco esse
questionamento dela que deixa de ser o
produco trio para ser uma coisa mais
Ampla e mais misturada e isso
provavelmente muda como a gente vê
topologias de times E aí eu achei a
provocação interessante Porque de fato
Se eu olhar no meu dia a dia hoje né
versus o que eu tinha um ano atrás Cara
eu tenho muito mais tempo para poder
pensar e buscar coisas diferentes do que
o tempo que eu passava por exemplo
estruturando apresentação material etc
porque cada vez que eu tinha que fazer
uma nova eu tinha que gastar o tempo ali
estruturando aquela ideia então isso
isso foi um ponto muito bom e aí teve um
outro lado que ela trouxe que é na
verdade a gente vai gerir times de
pessoas né então pros líderes times de
pessoas e times de Agentes então parte
do seu time vão ser você vai ter sei lá
beleza eu como GPM vou ter lá duas
pessoas que são mistas ali no product
trio e mais seis agentes que vão estar
fazendo Sei lá as análises de dados
olhando behavior tomando decisão
decidindo se escala um experimento ou
não sem um ser humano né tomando essa
decisão Mas você vai ser o gestor desse
agente Então o que muda nessa
perspectiva também é como que a gente
treina as pessoas para elas serem
gestores dos agentes e das pessoas
porque Vão você vai ter que trabalhar
vai ter que ser mais ter que ter essa
habilidade dupla né Então essas foram as
coisas legais que eu achei da Claire
parada que eu que eu peguei muito
assistindo a palestra dela que o Len
divulgou as primeiras palestras de de
para mim e eu lembrei de uma outra
palestra que eu vi que era inteligência
a é inteligências a service né No final
das contas que é um pouco isso que você
falou de eh É ISO você não precisa ter
necessariamente eh gastar todo o seu seu
conhecimento ali naquela coisa ou para
processar muitas coisas vai ser muito
mais para analisar do que de fato você
gasta mais você tem mais tempo para
fazer esses 25% do que necessariamente
para todo o processo manual do 75 por C
né e e é isso me remete cada vez mais o
lance que a gente até comentou isso em
Papos na arena assim que é o lance de
aprender a aprender né que acho que a
profissão de produto tem muito isso né
de ter que aprender a aprender não só de
produto mas eh é isso né as coisas estão
evoluindo tão eh tão evoluindo assim no
num nível que putz é isso quanto mais
você não precisa ser especialista
naquilo mas você precisa saber mexer nas
ferramentas né e elas vão fazer um
trabalho para você eh ontem mesmo tava
conversando com com a x eu tava montando
um um GPT para pegar todos os a
transcrição de todos os podcasts para
para ser nosso GPT pra gente quando a
gente quiser lembrar de algum episódio
etc e aí eu pô fui fazer essa Transform
lá e assim não sei zero do Google script
zero zero zero e aí eu pedi pro GPT lá e
aí ele falou cara tá aqui aqui você
coloca tal chave aqui você coloca tal
chave e é isso aí só que uma das coisas
que eu falei para ele eu fiz o copy and
paste falei tá bom agora explica sem ser
no código Como que você fez isso e cada
aí eu entendi a parada assim mas é isso
enquanto tava Processando o negócio lá
eu tava só Caraca entendi agora Como que
você fez etc e é muito nisso né Quanto
mais você sabe essas coisas mais você
vai ganhar esse tempo para você
gerenciar os seus Agents né e uma das
coisas que ela fala também bem no final
lá que nas quanto mais das posições de
liderança discussão de Budget e tudo
mais essas discussões vão ter cada vez
mais no dia a dia né que ao invés de
beleza eu preciso contratar mais x
pessoas aqui pro meu time ou esse bundle
de ferramentas aqui de ai Agents pode
resolver isso né com pessoas que vão
conseguir menos pessoas mas que elas vão
conseguir manipular essas ferramentas e
trabalhar com elas muito mais né cara eu
não sei onde que eu li isso ou se Ouvi
algum podcast mais um cara falando que
já nas discussões atuais que ele tem de
aprovação de contratações Ele já fala
cara me prova que isso não dá para fazer
com ai de um jeito mais barato e a
depois que você me provar aí sim a gente
conversa sobre sobre novas contratações
Então isso que a que a Fernanda falou de
que isso vai mudar estruturalmente a
topologia das empresas a discussão mesmo
de pessoas isso é super real é uma das
coisas que é legal de de refle eu acho
que a discussão de Budget ela já
acontece né a gente tem Ah eu vou ter um
analista de dados ou vou ter um agente
fazendo isso a gente tá escalando com a
gente muita coisa Ah vou ter mais
operação ou vou resolver isso via
produto né não e Tem coisa que a gente
Decidiu não resolver via produto eu tô
resolvendo via agente o agente vai pegar
aquela planilha vai fazer a b c d que é
uma pessoa teria que fazer e vai subir a
atualização do preço x y z então dá para
você você começa a escolher inclusive
melhor o que que você vai produtizar
primeiro né então isso também tá
ajudando a gente a pensar beleza eu
tenho um backoffice normalmente o
backoffice que é o mais negligenciado
por produto muitas vezes a gente não faz
as coisas direitinho no Office
eh os agentes aí eles podem ter muita
força porque eles vão fazer o trabalho
que a pessoa de produto não quis fazer
para automatizar ou não teve Budget ou
não tinha pessoa desenvolvedora
disponível também porque é sempre
despriorizado Então acho que ganha um
outro olhar assim Se as pessoas
conseguirem entender que os agentes
podem resolver os problemas Então
depende menos de produto e a pessoa de
produto começa a ser mais a pessoa que
constrói os agentes para resolver esse
problema e menos construir o produto
isso é uma coisa legal de refletir e eu
gosto de pensar e a é como se fosse co
inteligência tem até um livro que chama
co inteligência super rapidinho de ler
recomendo assim ele fala exatamente
disso assim o quanto você tem que
aprender a usar ai como parte do seu da
sua inteligência eh não vai ser 100% mas
essa parte ela é importante você
aprender que é como se fosse imagina que
sei lá quando há 20 anos né a gente um
pouco mais jovem Vamos lá há tantos anos
atrás quando a gente começou a trabalhar
tinha que saber
Excel então é o mesmo paradigma assim ah
você tinha que saber Excel tinha que
saber el som V essas coisas Agora você
vai ter que saber escrever script para
trabalhar com super interessante ISO que
você falo do do backoffice né de ser
sempre um After tos ali e é aquela coisa
que não tem design né sempre um monte de
tabela mesmo que o Dev ali mesmo fez e
eu fiquei pensando aqui de cara num
futuro onde um agente resolve essas
coisas que precisam do backoffice você
talvez não precise mais de interface
também Eh você precisa de uma interface
que o agente interage que pode ser só um
Jason eh ali então você muda de fato
muitos elementos do trabalho
E aí só prar a pergunta e a palestra
também que você falou que foi super
impactante fo gente não dá fazer duas
perguntas na mesma pergunta PR mim a
pessoa com TDH ela sempre vai comer uma
eu sempre como uma pergunta então muito
obrigado por me lembrar que tinha mais
na
pergunta então da o que que eu achei
legal assim ela TR uma visão
de conir uma visão de de produto em cima
de uma
Persona Então imagina
que o que que eles fizeram lá no YouTube
Studios Eles criaram uma Persona
Sofia e a Sofia Ela era uma Creator que
não sabia que era Creator era sei lá era
surfista que de vez em quando postava os
vídeos dela surfando e etc e aí eles
construíram toda a narrativa da visão de
produto em cima da Sofia saindo dessa
pessoa que só postava os vídeos para pra
Sofia a pessoa que putz é um Creator que
vive disso eh que agora tem a voz dela
ampliada que ela encontrou o jeito dela
de falar que eles conseguiram ajudar o
que que eram os conteúdos paraa Sofie
então assim na hora de contar a história
da visão de produto com uma pessoa ficou
muito mais fácil de entender porque
humanizou a gente tende a falar fazer
aqueles coisas bonita gráfico não sei
que quando contou seend Não essa pessoa
ela fazia isso aí depois aí isso aí
depois isso depois isso essa aqui é a
visão de produt bem mais fácil de
explicar assim noa e voltando um
pouquinho pra ai né que foi mais o tema
da da palestra da da clire Além disso né
também um dos painéis principais era um
bate-papo entre os cpos da Open ai e da
antropic né juntou ali os dois grandes
gigantes da área para trocarem uma ideia
né e queria que você trouxesse pô que
mais que você viu de teve mais coisas de
ai E como que você avalia a qualidade do
que foi falado entendi que você gostou
muito da da da Claire ali mas teve
outras coisas assim que geraram muito
Insight para você sobre esse assunto
cara assim so teve o o papo né dos dois
cpos o Kevin eu tinha dado a sorte de
est num outro evento duas semanas antes
que ele tava eh
então com menos pessoas Então eu tinha
consumo fazer pergunta o
o E aí o engraçado a primeira pergunta
que fizeram né pro CPO da antropic Ah
mas e aí como imagina que alguém parou e
pensou ah vou contratar o cofounder aqui
do Instagram para ser o CPO sabe
tipo como que chegaram nessa nessa
conclusão O que é engraçado pensando
hoje tipo realmente assim né ninguém
talvez ninguém pensasse que essa era uma
possibilidade E aí falando mais de
produto né o que eles trouxeram de
produtos com desenvolvimento produtos de
como é o desenvolvimento de produto com
eles né nas duas realidades é que eles
não conseguem ter uma visão muito de
longo prazo no final das contas porque
as coisas estão sendo descobertas
imagina que os modelos estão melhorando
e as pessoas estão aprendendo coisas
novas Então você vai dar uma
previsibilidade a previsibilidade ela
não é mais tão tão justa porque você vai
falar Beleza o modelo vai est pronto
daqui a três meses a gente não sabe a
gente estima que sim sabe se ele vai
estar funcionando se não vai então você
a previsibilidade ela muda essa relação
de previsibilidade com ro map né e muda
o que que você vai fazer porque às vezes
eles falam Ah seria muito legal eles
contando seria muito legal que isso aqui
isso aqui acontecesse Ah beleza aí o
cientista fala beleza mas isso a gente
já descobriu que faz é que a gente não
achou que era importante sabe então muda
um pouco a dinâmica de como que você vai
saber o que que foi descoberto o que que
pode virar produto produtizar e tal
então eles estavam falando eles
trouxeram muito essa discussão do como
que eles estão tendo que rever eh a
forma como o produto atua
eh num produto né como Open entropic o
outro lado foi
o Quando você pensa em experiência Você
vai pensar sobre Que tipo de behavior
você quer que o seu produto de ai tenha
então o o CP dantop que trouxe Ah um
consumidor um cliente meu virou para mim
e falou ah não porque o seu é mais
distante né Ele é não é tão próximo tipo
o chat GPT ele é mais humano tá ali mais
próximo Então você vai ter que pensar
que tipo de behav você quer no seu
eh no seu modelo n ali no llm enfim isso
era uma coisa
e e um pouco do que você tava falando
ali de de interface né
Eh muda um pouco lógica da interface
porque eu não falo mais sobre clica aqui
clica ali você vai ser exposto a essas
coisas mas é muito
como imagina que eu vou fazer uma coisa
bem futurista e bem e bem dramática
Agora imagina que não precise mais ter
aplicativo não existe mais nenhum
aplicativo o que tem são apis que
disparam serviços e esses serviços
disparam alguma coisa eh
designers de serviço vão ganhar vão ser
muito mais relevant do que PED uma outra
discussão e aí você tem que começar a
pensar a experiência numa outra lógica
né então quando eu tô construindo a
experiência Eu tô construindo a
experiência para alguém fazer essa ação
para mim e esse alguém tomar essa
decisão não sei se vocês viram que o
grinder soltou que eles estão fazendo os
agentes que os agentes primeiro antes
das pessoas interagirem então Ah beleza
eu fiquei interessada aqui no ur os
nossos agentes Vão bater um papo os
nossos agentes decidem se vale a pena
continuar ou não vale a pena a gente
começa a conversar que aí pensa Já
cortou o small Talk começo conversa
chata de
desinteresse até sabendo mais da pessoa
então muito do que eles trouxeram assim
como
que muda a forma de fazer produto e como
que muda das pessoas né muda a forma
como as pessoas vão agir e a
responsabilidade de
isso dentro de um produto de quando você
tá construindo dei E aí muito do que
eles trouxeram pô imagina quando eles
criaram quando né o cofounder né do
Instagram criou o Instagram sabia-se
muito pouco sobre rede social a gente
foi aprendendo ao longo do tempo sobre
legislação outras coisas que cara não se
pensava antes o que vale a pena nessa
história né nessa jornada pensar a gente
nos últimos 8 anos foi muito sobre redes
sociais e aprendeu-se um monte né de de
conceitos de coisas que a gente deveria
ou não deveria fazer do and don't E aí
eu acho que a gente vai para para criar
uma tecnologia de a um Pouco Mais maduro
também então essa foi um pouco do que
eles trouxeram ali que eu achei reflexão
bem boa e até voltando que você falou lá
no início né puto quem que ia pensar que
o Calder do Instagram ia na CPO da
antropic tem uma entrevista muito da
hora do Mike Krieger que é brasileiro
para quem não sabe né eh pro Podcast do
Decoder lá do The verd onde ele fala
bastante sobre isso é um cara que tá
pensando e tentando criar coisas de ai a
tem um tempo né eles criaram o artifact
que era um app de notícias eh com ai um
tempo atrás que não não deu certo né
antes dele vir então é um papo muito
interessante para quem quiser aprofundar
um pouco mais nessa pessoa específico o
Mike é claramente um cara que pensa
bastante produto pensa bastante ai ali
então Super Interessante inclusive nessa
mesma linha tem dois livros para indicar
e contando a história um pouco que é o
clique de 1 bilhão de Dólares que conta
Bem a História e tem um que é no Filter
os bastidores do Instagram que também é
muito bom esse eu preferi esse inclusive
do que o do que outro e também fala
bastante da história do do Mike do o
outro cof lá que eu esqueci o nome agora
também é é o Kevin sinom Kevin exato e
Caraca vocês são muito bom com o nome
velho não consigo lembrar o nome de
ninguém eu vou
só mas e teve mais alguma outra palestra
que que você da Caria ou algum outro
insid assim que te que te marcou cara
Teve teve mais coisas legais assim em
geral né Então teve
muita discussão sobre como gerar Impacto
e e principalmente Como Influenciar
decisões e como que a gente né cada vez
mais Coloca nesse lugar teve uma da
figma que parecia bobinha confesso
quando eu olhei eu falei esse
negócio não vai ser
interessante mas eles trouxeram um ponto
de provocação que era a história do
figma
slides né é
e E aí ela trouxe uma provocação do tipo
cara quando a gente tá fazendo uma
apresentação de produto a gente sempre
começa pelo contexto vamos dar o
contexto contar a história contar o que
a gente pesquisou para depois chegar na
solução sendo que o stakeholder ele quer
ver a solução então você vai prender 20
minutos da atenção da pessoa com
você porque não é aquilo que ela quer
ela quer ver a solução Então como que
você inverte a lógica conta a partir de
você mostrando a solução você constrói o
storytelling do contexto então parecia
bobeira falei cara tipo uma coisa sobre
Como apresentar coisas de produto sei lá
aí vem o o ego pô faço isso há um tempão
velho aí ela foi mostrou um jeito eu
falei é faço errado melhor fazer assim
ainda bem que eu fiquei aqui e não
saí muito melhor fiz um teste na semana
seguinte foi um caos mas funcionou o
ponto dela que é eu tive muito mais
atenção das pessoas desde o começo para
explicar o porqu a gente tava indo para
aquela solução do que o contrário Então
foi muito mais fácil falar Beleza a
gente porque era um o que a gente fez lá
né o que eu usei de exemplo eu peguei um
negócio que era totalmente diferente do
que todo mundo
esperava só que eu tinha que construir o
racional da onde a gente saiu o por T
tal tal mas essa aqui é a solução que a
gente vai o que eu fiz foi mostrei a
solução todo mundo em choque meu Deus é
isso que a gente quer cérebro de um lado
pro outro de todo mundo tá tá tá E aí
você vai construir em cima mas pensa bem
por que que a gente tá fazendo isso aqui
porque quando a gente entrevistou o
usuário veio essa essa informação e aí
Isso aqui faz sentido Ah agora eu
entendi mas aí você já tirou a ansiedade
da tela você já deu a discussão sabe
tipo beleza toma discussão aqui essa é a
solução E aí foi muito mais interessante
de fato eu falei cara eu prendo muito
mais a atenção quando eu faço isso e a
discussão foi muito mais produtiva para
todo mundo ouv Putz Então é isso que o
consumidor tá dizendo na entrevista
quando a gente testou foi isso aqui que
aconteceu do que se eu explicasse todo
esse contexto depois trazer a solução
então essa foi uma coisa legal e teve
uma outra que era da que era do do
WhatsApp que ela esqueci o nome dela
vocês são bons vocês vão saber o nome
dela já já
eh e a ela falando sobre
simplicidade né que cara se aquele
componente todo mundo usa desse jeito
para que que você vai fazer diferente se
o envar é uma é um triangulo Zinho de
lado por que que você quer fazer
diferente tipo tira o esforço cognitivo
do usuário sabe qual é um negócio meio
Óbvio mas às vezes Alguém tem que falar
para você falar É né então para quê E se
o seu negócio é sobr mensagem é sobr
mensagem não adiciona um monte de coisa
e aconteceu quando eu voltei de lá
olhando pro produto do Zé meu Deus sobre
vender cerveja tipo eu tenho que fazer
isso muito bem as outras coisas não
importam então é é meio que eu gosto
desses eventos que são conceitos que são
básicos mas que a gente precisa às vezes
que alguém fale para você voltar pro
eixo sabe tipo ou para de se perder
vamos lá volta aqui não super faz
sentido
e ainda no campo das palestras né o Len
mesmo ele fez uma trad ali no Linkedin
no Twitter com as reflexões dele sobre o
evento e ele falou bastante sobre parte
do que ele ter atribuir o sucesso e as
pessoas terem gostado as palestras terem
sido mais focadas em conselhos práticos
aplicáveis eu acho que muito do que você
trouxe agora foi que você ia falou
algumas coisas que você pegou e no dia
seguinte ou logo um pouco tempo depois
você foi lá e aplicou ou olhou com
aquela Ótica né você saiu de lá então
com essa coisa de Tipo pô teve várias
coisas que eu ouvi aqui e que eu posso
aplicar no meu dia a dia né você teve
esse mesmo filho sim é eu achei que foi
muito bom nesse sentido assim sabe tipo
por isso que eu falei são coisas que não
é que alguém tá falando a
ciência da Nasa assim vamos lá dominar
mar não sabe quando alguém meio que
volta pro pro básico assim fala cara ó
eu fiz isso isso e isso aqui funcionou
você fala Bom tipo ah CPO da Netflix ela
falou ah quando ela chegou que tinha 45%
dos usuários do Netflix eram usuários de
contas que estavam eh compartilhadas né
então o grande problema deles de contas
compartilhadas e tal e ela falando sobre
não abrir mão da do que é o Netflix que
é assistir de qualquer lugar qualquer
conteúdo Então como que você faz uma
solução sem abrir mão da sua essência
sem abrir mão do que é importante sem
abrir mão da obsessão pelo consumidor né
pelo customer Obsession Porque no final
das contas assim aquelas contas
compartilhadas tinham configurações de
família que eram importantes para aquela
pessoa então quando você entra para essa
discussão você entrou na discussão do
que que é configuração de família e aí
isso é uma outro tipo de discussão eu
não tô mais falando sobre conta plano
etc tô falando tendo outra discussão
então isso foi legal para pensar assim
tá bom o o customer Obsession é eu vou
adequar a minha solução eu não vou abrir
mão disso aqui que é meu princípio muito
forte e eu tenho que fazer de um jeito
que eu não vá ferir
eh coisas que são conceitos muito básic
muito muito forte para as pessoas né
então isso foi legal também de de olhar
e é isso assim foram coisas as pessoas
foram contando as histórias do que elas
fizeram E aí fica muito mais fácil de
você tangibilizar eh no seu dia a dia
também e realmente eu saí de lá tipo
fazendo várias coisas que a galera falou
fora o que você fora o que eu troquei de
ideia assim então foi muito bom é meio
que você tá com seus coleguinhas
sabe tipo caramba todo mundo aqui gosta
de produto todo mundo faz a mesma coisa
então um pode dar conselho pro outro
então é uma grande quinta série ali e
nessa linha da da quinta série o Len
também comentou sobre a importância dos
round tables né que rolaram e e também
foi uma parada que eu comentei bastante
quando rolou o product Leader summit
assim
e como foram quais Que você participou e
e como que você achou que foi essas
round tables Cara eu tenho uma crítica A
round table porque ele era nos mesmos
horários das dos stales né E aí eu só
fui um round table
mas todos os
a cada Du dois dois toques tinha uma
pausa de mais ou menos 15 minutos que
dava para trocar ideia com a galera hora
do almoço Óbvio você troca mais ideia
porque você sent para almoçar com um
monte de gente desconhecida gasta todo
seu inglês ali
eh então o o round table em si é bom
para você conhecer as pessoas mas se eu
vou te falar assim você vai discutir
sobre um tema e era muito sobre eh
como aumentar a maturidade de produto
que é um tema que eu tô um pouco mais à
frente não era bem esse o nome é um nome
mais bonito mas era nessa linha então
meio que cada um contando um pouco a
história do que que tem do que que passa
né então chama P PM Isso tem em qualquer
lugar eh cham PM de projeto isso também
tem em qualquer lugar e então tem
algumas coisas que meio que acho que
round table assim como ele tem temas
definidos ele ajuda você a meio que se
conectar com pessoas que estão com
problemas muito similares ao seu e que
alguns elas resolveram diferente do que
você tá tentando resolver então você
consegue pegar algumas inspirações então
é muito bom por
isso só que eu gostei mais das conversas
informais do que dos round
tables então tipo você tá sentado do
lado de alguém sei lá quem é esse Alé
não conheço e aí tudo bom Não sei que
trabalha onde você faz
o Isso é para mim era muito mais rico e
como as pessoas que estavam al eram
produto e acho que tava todo mundoo meio
que disposto a isso então era muito
fácil assim você tava esperando o
próximo toque e alguém do seu lado você
começar a bater papo então eu levantava
sempre a cada troca e sentava em lugares
diferentes tanto você vê minha foto o
meu tô no fundo o meu tô do lado eu tô T
do outro tô na frente então eu fui
andando para conhecer pessoas diferentes
eh nesses intervalos E aí eu acho que
isso foi muito rico também assim ter as
pessoas disponíveis para trocar você
criou seus round table pockets né round
table One One aleatório as temas
aleatórios bom demais e engatando nisso
né falando do evento e do que que ele é
diferente de outros que você já foi que
que você acha que foi principal
diferença assim de outros eventos que
você já tenha ido que você tenha curtido
seja dentro ou fora do Brasil assim
Então qual que foi o ponto alto cara
primeiro eu saí Exausta né de intervent
Talk inglês falando em inglês para quem
não faz isso o dia inteiro todos os dias
e olha que eu trabalho metade do meu dia
eu devo falar inglês então foi foi
puxado eu vi que às vezes eu não
compreendo algumas coisas que as pessoas
falam muito rápido que é muito mais
fácil entender o inglês de quem não é
nativo do que De quem é nativo
eh e acho que o que eu vi de diferente
assim uma coisa que eu gostei muito
assim
meio que você antes de ir você sabia
quem eram as pessoas que iam estar no
evento Então tinha uma
lista que você olhava eh Quem eram as
pessoas que iam est lá e você podia meio
que adicionar aquela pessoa no seu no
seu circulozinho e falar Putz beleza
essa pessoa eu quero falar e aí você vê
se essa pessoa tá na round table que
você vai então tem isso achei muito
legal porque então eu posso
intencionalmente queria me conectar com
a alguém que era da wao que é daquele
carro que dirige sozinho cara um negócio
muito diferente da minha realidade né
Falei pô já que eu vou né Deixa eu falar
que as pessoas estão fazendo coisas
muito diferentes do que eu tô fazendo no
dia a dia e aí você conseguia ver ah
Fulano Dao vai est na round table x aí
você vai lá ou você vê a carinha da
pessoa aí você na hora do almoço dá uma
caçada assim sabe tipo hum ah é aquele
ali vou sentar ali tipo oi tudo bom Sabi
sentei aqui por caso que loucura me
Stalker né É mas é bom porque você tem
muito mais intenção assim no final das
contas com quem que você vai trocar fora
que depois você fica com o contato das
pessoas assim você vai trocando pós
evento né que eu acho que é o que tá
acontecendo agora também então tipo ah
uma pessoa me chama para Beleza então
vamos trocar ideia
sobre um negócio meio complexo ali de eh
como você humaniza um pouco as relações
com EA enfim até que ponto vai chegar
isso E aí é legal assim eu gosto de
Brisa tá de vamos filosofar so tal coisa
eu gosto quando as pessoas foram presso
eu falo maneiro eh menos sobre
problema e mais sobre abrir a mente
assim então eu acho que é isso assim que
esse evento ajudou foi um você sabia
quem eram as pessoas que tavam ali no
evento Então você podia ter intenção no
Stalker né Putz eu quero falar com tal
pessoa eh
você sabia quem ia est na round table
então eu não ia para round table tipo
Putz eu não sei quem vai est lá não vai
est fulano de tal empresa tal empresa
tal empresa tu empresa caramba essas
empresas Têm alguma similaridade comigo
então faz sentido solar lá então essas
coisas eu achei diferente o fato deles
falarem que eles estavam fazendo uma
curadoria eh ah só tem pessoas aqui que
a gente meio que aprovou que passou num
crio isso dá uma segurança também eh de
de senioridade que você vai encontrar
ali então Puts eu sabia que não ia ter
gente que tava começando na carreira de
produto eh naquele momento que tinha
acabado de fazer transição não todo
mundo ali já tinha mais de 5 anos de
experiência em produto então eu eu tinha
a a troca né ela ficava mais rápida no
final das contas porque eu já sabia mais
ou menos que tá bom então cara você já
tem experiência em produto a gente não
vai falar de coisa básica a gente pode
ir para coisa mais mais profunda mais
Ampla então isso eu achei bom do que os
outros e acho que o conteúdo foi muito
bem foi nailed sabe tipo ele mandou bem
nas pessoas que foram e nos temas assim
b então só para confirmar n antes a
gente fechar aqui pro papum
eh o evento atendeu suas expectativas
então ano que vem na segunda edição se
tiver você vai é não se o dólar
continuar aumentando desse jeito talvez
não
é então vamos orar para que isso não
aconteça
mas assim eu acho que valeu a pena tá eh
eu acho que foi não foi barato não é um
evento barato de né uma grana ainda mais
porque o dólar tá muito alto pro real
você bota passagem fica um pouco mais
caro mas na minha opinião sim se tiver a
possibilidade de se você tiver que fazer
Budget esse ano você é líder de produto
que tem que fazer Budget esse ano para
considerar ano que vem coloque no seu
Budget a uma ida ao Len porque vale a
pena Novembro é não podia ser mais
actionable esse esse conselho né
Novembro época de discutir Budget do ano
que vem agora é o momento eu coloquei já
no do ano que vem coloquei já subida do
os outos bot os outros os outros
diretores de produto para irem também a
gente já considera isso aí se aprovarem
beleza se não aprovarem a gente vê o que
a gente faz mas assim considerem porque
vale a pena
eh eu achei entre ele e o Mind the
product né que foram os dois
internacionais de produto
especificamente que eu fui eu acho que
eles têm propósitos diferentes tá eh o
Mind the product ele tem um conteúdo bom
mas ele tem menos sobre conexão o Len
ele tinha mais sobre conexão sobre
conhecer pessoas e se conectar
eh em termos de qualidade de conteúdo eu
acho que ele é muito parecido com os
eventos que a gente tem aqui tá Ah eu
não acho que a gente sim eu acho que a
gente Às vezes tem essa síndrome de de
virar lata mas a gente tem muita coisa
boa muita gente boa
então o que eu acho é que sim se você
pegar as pessoas muito boa de produto do
jeito que ele pegou e colocar para falar
se vai ter a mesma qualidade que você
teve no Len menos os CPO de Open anop
porque isso a gente não tem aqui ainda E
ai a gente ainda tá um pouco atrás mas
de resto Cara eu acho que a gente não
fica nada
atrás justíssimo
justíssimo Bora lá pro nosso batebola
então Fernanda Bora Pera aí que eu tava
abrindo aqui o o bola para me
preparar o que que você ia
falar boa vamos começar então PR você
gerenciamento de produto em um twit Qual
a emoção que seu produto causa no
usuário principal habilidade de uma
pessoa de produto cara eu respondi essa
pergunta hoje Fizeram essa pergunta
falei três eu diria que a
principal é você conseguir ser a pessoa
que levanta a bandeira do consumer Cent
consumer for você precisa ter essa esse
estômago para lidar é com a dificuldade
que às vezes é ser essa pessoa algum
livro que você recomenda e não precisa
ser de produto tá pode ser qualquer
livro cara na linha de ai eu recomendo
co inteligên muito bom
sim fácil de ler rápido você tá
assistindo alguma série no momento qual
ou então senão Qual que você recomenda
pra galera Car Eu tô assistindo novela
no momento não tô uma pessoa de série eu
tô assistindo mania de você eu tô
achando maravilhoso eu e mess assim ó
Cara acho a m é ótima entendeu
eh já torci contra Mavi a favor de Mavi
é uma loucura então tô noveleira não tô
na fase de série
cabeção que eu tô trabalhando tanto que
aí ver a novela me dá uma tipo dá uma
alienada sabe na mente fala ei
problema lá que ninguém tem olha a outra
vivendo na
lancha eu tava no veleiro até acabar
Renascer Renascer tava
por foi muito boa também mas eu não eu
não peguei o ritmo do Renascer mas da
mania de você eu peguei o ritmo é muito
bom e música ou artista Predileto banda
que que toca no seu Spotify é meu
Spotify é muito aleatório né eu consigo
ouvir sei lá de Pablo vitar A metálica
mas se eu tivesse que dizer preferido
provavelmente a Pablo é minha predileta
e
Ludmila sejam os dois top vamos saber
daqui a pouco no retrospectiva Spotify
se é isso mesmo você eu estou me
enganando tá chegando quem ainda quer
salvar a retrospectiva do ano acho que
ainda dá tempo mas tá quase e qual coisa
que você não abre mão da sua rotina Cara
eu tenho que ter algum momento na semana
com a minha família com os dois jovens
que estão aqui do lado jogando eh ou
sentar tipo para comer alguma coisa e
fofocar ou com a minha esposa tipo sair
para jantar
eh porque eles me ajudam a
Desconectar do trabalho dos problemas
então tipo cara você tá com os
adolescentes porque eles vieram contar
uma fofoca da escola é muito bom gente
olha fofoca de de escola da cidade eh e
aí eu conto fofocas do trabalho que eu
não posso contar as fofocas de trabalho
para as pessoas eu conto para eles
entendeu
É é uma forma Ah você não pode como
liderança você não pode contar tudo pro
seu time você não pode eu conto pros
pros meninos que não entendem prova
nenhuma faam Ah tá beleza isso aí mas
pelo menos eu consegui falar e para
finalizar aqui o nosso papum seu produto
Favorito não vale Z delivery É eu sabia
que i l cara eu gosto muito do aud
porque eu me dou muito bem com audiobook
Então vou fugir um pouco do
padrão eu tenho mais
para absorver com audiobook do que lendo
e eu descobri isso depois de ouvir
vários livros
eh e até por conta do do TDH assim tava
falando PR minha esposa que eu leio eu
consigo ficar conversando com você e
continuar lendo Como se eu tivesse lendo
então eu absorvo muito pouco na leitura
Quando é áudio eu eu acho interessante
aí para minha atenção para escutar então
o aud me ajuda muito tipo inteligência
foi um livro que eu escutei eh e essa
história de ter que ficar viajando de um
lado pro outro eh eu uso eu baixo ele
offline e basicamente vou no avião
escutando ou os nosso escritório tem um
escritório em Campinas eu vou para
Campinas escutando alguma coisa show de
bola já foi produto da semana do Artur
aqui também né inclusive né artz já já e
o Jeff deve feliz né porque assim a
maioria das pessoas que a gente faz O
papum ou fala o Kindle ou fala o áudio
vol Pois é alguém tá ganhando dinheiro
né n isso é famosa história né alguém tá
vendendo a
par exato exato E aí eu não posso deixar
de indicar então para você não sei se
você já viu que é o spit fy se você tá
procurando se você gosta de ouvir as
coisas tem um app que chama speit fy
eles não me pagam nada não tá Eles
podiam Patrocinar o tanto que eu já
falei deles aqui mas é porque é muito
bom eles ele tipo basicamente eh lê eh
tipo coloca áudio em qualquer conteúdo
seu sabe deixa eu cair as coisas ele
coloca áudio e dá para você colocar a
voz dos Famosos tem da tayor Swift do
Cará que maneiro é eu escuto as paradas
tudo no Snoop
Dog muito bom eu vi um outro dia que é
um notebook LM do Google que você sobe
os artigos e ele transforma Aquilo num
podcast eu falei cara isso é muito
maravilhoso não vou ter mais que tentar
ler artigo difícil e fica muito bom é
muito bom por isso que eu acho assim
fica muito bom cara vai mudar muda muito
a nossa realidade assim eu fico até com
dó quando falando na escola que eles não
podem usar o chat CPT eu falei não vamos
usar aqui um bote para você faz as
coisas para você porque assim se você
não aprender agora na hora que você
tiver que trabalhar você vai ter que
saber eu fico triste de ter feito
mestrado antes dessa época velho eu só
olho ass eu falo velho que que mão
na roda seria isso
daqui ai muito bom Artur vamos pros
nossos produtos da semana bora bora bora
bora lá eu começo essa semana né porque
a semana passada você começou eu nunca
nunca gravo se você disser toda semana
que é a minha vez eu eu tô colocando na
ordem aqui justamente para isso não
acontecer cara o meu foi o Rapid api que
é basicamente um Marketplace de
api cara muito bom porque eu tô fazendo
as gambeta aqui com o zaaper integrando
ch GPT e tudo mais
e e cara ele tem um é basicamente isso
tem um monte de api lá pronta já para
você usar eu tava pegando uma que faz
transcript de do YouTube de vídeos do
YouTube cara funcionou muito bem aí você
pode pegar as versões pagas lá eles já
deixam pronto lá tem o o get post toda
parada lá e você só coloca a chave já tá
integrado com todos os zapier com o make
todas essas e ó mão mão na roda então HP
jpi como chama rid jpi exato te passo é
fiquei e tem muito tem muita coisa Tem
Esportes clima tem de tudo é bem massa
bem massa o meu é menos o meu é mais
divertido aqui que é o é joguinho falei
semana passada aí é tigrin né é tigrin é
tigr po F seria divertido né mas eu
falei as duas semanas atrás aí né que T
com saudade de falar de joguinho aqui e
o meu produto da semana é é meio jogo
meio não jogo que é o Pokémon TCG mobile
que que é o Pokémon TCG mobile para quem
conhece aí
Magic y m é o mais mais comum aqui né
que é aquele jogo de cartas ilustradas e
tal Pokémon ccg é basicamente a mesma
coisa só que de Pokémon né E então saiu
o aplicativo e e basicamente é o
aplicativo de colecionar carta de
Pokémon tem lá como você batalhar com
seus amigos mas nem cheguei na parte de
batalhar ainda tô só na parte de meio
que colecionar figurinha então para quem
gosta de Pokémon Eu gosto muito de
Pokémon Mas você coleciona só carta de
Pokémon digital ou carta de pokal só
digital é isso para mim tá sendo o
suficiente ele tem um cara coisas do des
né você tem lá uns Boosters que você
pode abrir todo dia né que são os
packzin de carta e aí cara você tem lá
um uma animaçãozinha de você passar o
dedo para riscar para rasgar o pacotinho
E aí ele rasga do jeito que você passou
o dedo então é todo um gimic que dá um
prazer Zinho ali de você fazer isso todo
dia então é a minha recomendação aí da
semana Pokémon TCG mobile Artur que que
a galera mandou pra gente essa semana ó
o Lucas mandou o aplicativo da Smiles a
pilon mandou o não uso de um aplicativo
que ela tá fazendo um detox do Instagram
e ela falou que tá sendo foi a melhor
coisa que aconteceu na semana dela Aí
não vale não é produto da semana não eu
não uso de um produto da semana dela o
Cloves mandou o quinto andar o o ner
mandou o clash pass a Karina mandou 99 o
Andrezinho mandou Du lingo o Glauco
mandou o CEP que é o app da creche da da
filha dele e o Lucão falou que os grupos
de os grupos é os eventos agora no
WhatsApp ão muito mais tudo o lance lá
de confirmar a notificação quem vai no
evento etc agora que liberou geral isso
tem agora rapaz tá bem tá muito bom Olha
só cara eu toda vez que alguém manda
quinto andar eu fico levemente triste
pela pessoa porque claramente ela tá na
pegada de se mudar e se mudar é uma
merda né procurar apartamento fazer
mudança então eu passei por isso recente
é muito bom depois tá na casa eentão o
processo até chegar lá Art Tu também a
gente se mudou próximo né Na época
próxima terrível Pô mas agora
quarto da i tá pronto já não é quando
você tá dentro eu tô amando aqui
apartamento e tal mas até chegar
Guerreiro Aqui também tá ó to coisas tá
uma maravilha e essa semana tem
recomendações além de app da semana
Artur tem tem duas recomendações aqui
Pois é cara eu voltei a assistir Silicon
vy velho e pô recomendo pra galera que é
muito é o é o é é o tipo The Office da
tecnologia
né É incrível o negócio é de 2000 e sei
lá quando mas que um monte de coisa eu
já passei por elas que é zoeira né Você
acha que é comédia eu fala Olha já já vi
isso aqui acontecendo Opa e tal é a
comédia da vida real né exato exato e o
Andrezinho mandou a a série do Yellow
Stone todo mundo eu assisti uns
episódios também essa tá na minha lista
um tempo PR assistir e agora Netflix
lançou uma cópia deles né também para
concorrer eu esqueci o nome agora mas é
alguma coisa cópia do Yellow Stone a
mesma coisa todo mundo com chapéu
fazenda e tudo mais teve uma uma cópia
do White Lotus da Netflix que é o casal
perfeito esse é legalzinho é uma boa
série para você matar no final de semana
casal perfeito é tipo nada a Série S de
10 ali mas divertido sa quando você quer
ver e a dancinha do de abertura da série
é muit tá é cara eu assisti essa série é
boa mesmo é legal mesmo pô início é a
parte mais legal a dancinha realmente é
é muito bom e o plot twist no final
também é gostei não é nada incrível mas
n é divertido é isso é muito bom e com
isso a gente caminha pro encerramento do
programa aqui de hoje e queria mais uma
vez agradecer Fernanda muito obrigado
pelo seu tempo muito obrigado por
compartilhar aqui com os nossos ouvintes
a sua experiência de est lá no evento
dedicar aí esse tempinho para falar com
a gente e aí momento é seu se quiser
deixar um recado final fica à vontade
quiser deixar um cupom do Zé aí pra
galera também he fica à
vontade o microfone é seu Obrigado pelo
convite cupom todo mundo tem É só baixar
o Zé e entrar lá que você vai receber
cupom de alguma de alguma forma entendeu
Se você usar mais você vai receber mais
cupom Então tudo depende da pessoa
querer usar entendeu querendo querendo
usar você vai ganhar cupom e aproveita
as promoções da Black Friday no z tá bem
bem forte não posso falar mas se você
quer comprar cerveja e destilados
aguardaria que vai ser bom
eh e de recado finalo que é sempre que
precisarem contem comigo
eh para para est aqui para trocar ideia
se quiserem depois a gente volta para
falar de outros temas mais legais e mais
uma vez obrigada pelo convite vamos
querer com certeza E e essa seria a
melhor cupom promoção que a gente daria
nesse podcast né tipo melhor do que
qualquer evento cupom de cerveja então
fica aí a dica pra galera esperar a
black do Zé vou aproveitar certamente
sou um não vou dizer que um consumidor
acido porque é meio né F aparecendo
ali outra cois não mas não vende só
cerveja no Zé no Zé vende carne vende
carvão vende todinho você sabia que
vende todinho todinho gor nunca cheguei
nessa parte essa aba do meu fica
escondida
ali outras coisas que eu compro bastante
é isotônico e cerveja zero agora Corona
Corona zero boa indicação boa Corona zer
M Corona zero é muito boa velho é é real
aqui essa essa uma excelente dica
de produto da semana Corona zero
principalmente pra galera 30 anos mais
aí ó cerveja zero é muito bom muito bom
reforçando aí os recados né não se
esqueça lá da cinco estrelas deixar seu
comentário deixar like seguir a gente lá
nas redes eu sou o @x O Artur é o @
Artur Close com k e tem o @ product
Arena aí no Instagram no Twitter no
Linkedin Então segue lá que a gente
sempre posta coisa estamos postando
agora os cortes do programa né então tem
vários cortes ao longo aí da semana
nosso editor de vídeos Artur Castro aí
tá comandando Eu nada ai achei uma
ferramenta aqui I falar sí na
coisa de humano não complemento lá S eu
só complemento é isso ela faz os 75% eu
só tenho que esticar D só o seu
toquezinho né o toque o refinamento ali
muito bom aí tá vendo você ganhou mais
uma profissão editor de vídeo tá vendo
aí ó é isso aí e é isso semana que vem
tem mais recado final aí Artur não só
agradecer mais uma vez fez sempre o
prazer e é isso a gente se vê e a gente
se ouve na arena até até semana que vem
valeu valeu vu
[Música]